Hi everyone, today we're reading "Hide-and-Seek Under the Sea".
Red Crab is having fun.
He's playing hide-and-seek with his friends.
"I can see someone in the coral reef," says Red Crab.
It's Purple Octopus!
"Boo!" cried Red Crab.
"I've found you!"
Purple Octopus and Red Crab are looking for the rest of their friends.
Red Crab spots someone behind the shipwreck.
Can you see who it is?
It's Blue Dolphin!
"Boo!" cries Red Crab.
"I've found you!"
The sea creatures still haven't found everyone.
There's someone hiding in the big rock cave.
Who could it be?
It's Green Turtle!
"Boo!" cries Red Crab.
"I've found you!"
"We've found everyone!" cries Purple Octopus.
"That was great fun!" says Green Turtle.
"Let's play again tomorrow!" calls Blue Dolphin.
"Goodbye everyone!" cries Red Crab.